je vous assure docteur françois et moi
nous sommes très inquiets
louis ne parle presque plus il passe son
temps dans le jardin à un marché en
ouvrant grand la bouche n'ont aucun son
ne sort de sa bouche est vraiment
impossible
d'accord donc nous le quittons pas des
yeux
enfin docteur qu'est ce qu'il a dit il
ne peut pas venir pour l'instant il aa
les malades allez voir il vient dès que
possible
il nous conseille de pia l'observer
attention justement le voilà qui arrive
peut-être ne torture pas assez sa fille
bayer ou alors il est devenu muet du
présent c'était souvent table on dirait
qu'ils voient rien non plus si vous
arrêtez de dire des stupidités jeu
pourra continuer à travailler
c'est incroyable ça tu le penses toi
c'est qu'ils ne seraient pas du tout
dans son état normal
mais dis-moi julie tu crois qu'on peut
devenir fou comme ça on à ce jour
l'agencé videront en rien qu'il faut
admettre que casimir a toujours été
complètement stupide quoi tu dis toi
même que tu as toujours été complètement
stupide moi non mais c'est ce que vous
racontez depuis tout à l'heure qui est
pardonnez-moi complète omar stupide à la
merci quand même
mais coûte quel humour si tu nous
expliquer ce qui t'arrive peut-être
qu'on ne poserait pas comme ça des
questions stupides complètement stupide
complètement si tu veux mais pourquoi
marche qui sans rien dire en ouvrant la
bouche je travaille mon vocabulaire
j'apprends une langue étrangère à ses
fantasmes et j'aurais jamais pensé à ça
revient sur toi pour ce qui est de la
communication entre les peuples
tu as toujours été en retard et qu'elles
ont
d'après tu as ça c'est un secret ah oui
alors tu parles de touba comme ça on
entend pas on comprend rien et après tu
nous fais la surprise
tu vois casimir j'ai tout compris rien
du tout tu n'as rien compris du tout
voilà allons quasiment ne te fâche pas
et explique nous pourquoi caf ont une
langue étrangère je veux bien mais à une
condition c'est que lui s'en aille au
bout très bien très bien très bien
parfait puisque c'est comme ça moi je
m'en vais ça tombe bien j'aime et ballon
allait ranger au revoir je lis tout cas
là on voit qu'ils me voir et bien voilà
tu sais l'autre jour on avait trempé
métier dans la rivière eh bien j'ai
rencontré quelqu'un que veut-il dire par
quelqu'un
et bien c'est une demoiselle
ah oui elle est très belle elle a des
des grands yeux noirs une couleur un
petit peu comme la mienne mais avec des
reflets rouge et doré malheureusement
nous ne parlons pas la même langue
alors on n'a pas pu se comprendre c'est
pour ça que je travaille
mikel lampard le talent langue et non
l'allemand non le groupe italien non non
non je peux pas te dire encore c'est
c'est un secret continuer à présenter
j'aimerais la connaît oui je pense bien
je serais ravi d'avoir une nouvelle amie
c'est vrai écoute je vais aller la voir
et puis si elle veut bien se la ramène
d'accord d'accord
elle s'appelle pénélope rap il dit moi
je suis beau oui tu te répond qu'une
glace fille
car ça va aller dépêche-toi joueur de
l'avoir mais oui mais oui des très
belles comme sa nouvelle à t'annoncer
lequel casimir a été chercher la
demoiselle étrangères pour laquelle il
apprend cette mystérieuse landreau
paraît qu'elle est très jolie très jolie
coquet copine julie
voilà je vous présente pénélope
mais dites lui quelque chose